[音楽]
goo 2
[拍手]
[音楽]
ni ん
今前に生きてきた中ねー
ゆっくりちょっとできないん
しっかりなった
何かあ
いないために
じゃじゃーん
[音楽]
いやー
今
手を挙げてください
そのできないなどでちゃった時
自分を
攻めてしまった経験があるのかどれ位いらっしゃいますか
その時どんなにも制した
今日は
皆さんの中にある障害血管策定という言葉に会すのイメージ
そしてあなたの中のできないことに対しての思い込みをもっと
ワクワクさせられるようなものに生えていけるような話をしたいと思います
バスはがし皆さん
できない壁にぶち当たったことがありますか
匹しましたん
私は高校生の時
まりそのいない人にぶち当たっていたんです
学校総合してみてください
過去には守らないといけない最低限のルールがあります
私の理想はこうでした
朝時間通り投稿する宿題をなくさずに期限ができます
授業を開いままデスク
床まで当たり前だっ
思われる方がいらっしゃると思いますもしかしたら全員を塗ってる私も向けたんです
でも私はこの灯り前だとされていることだ
ものすごくハードルが高かったんです
印象の方でした8年半まで方向しないといけないので鉢植えからシャワーをあり
シャワーを浴び始めて
で先に兵隊がないことに気づいて携帯をさらしうちに8時半に託します
遅刻をして咲く咳をしたはじめに気づくんです
消費は半減フェスが高く売る
そしてテスト中に寝てしまうんです
これはたちの現実でした
みんなと私はちょっと違うのかなぁ
みんなよりもできないことが多いのかなそんな足を折っているんじゃないのかな
またできなかった
私は自分を責め続けていました
当然自分で自分を最近やめくださいにお嬢配布を出しました
かーわーもしかしたら得意なこと苦手なことがはっきりわかるかもしれないから
病院5
そこで私はある診断を受けるんです
aab
ええええ乳してるよーという方のでからいらっしゃいますか
あ白羽ありがとうございます
日本語で言うと修理欠如多動性障害と言われてい
具体的に言うとこれは発達障害の一種で先天性で脳の機能的な障害だと言われています
阿部てないとか目が見えないとか物理的な障害とは家楽天の中から
障害なんですね
具体的にいつ特性があります一つ目
9注意深爪可能性見つめ
衝動性
でもこの特性は人によってこんなの出方が違うのです
私の場合は特に
普通の顔
衝動性にこんなハーイ頂きたいです
小野瀬枠
干拓したん
私は時間かもの管理
注意を持続させること
計画どおりに行動することが苦手でした
先程言った遅刻をする宿題を隠してしまう授業中店しまう
そのことは私のせいではなかった a 0 e 属性が誰が考えたんだ
トク子さんでも
診断を受けても私の現実が変わるわけではありませんでした
私は周囲と比べてい
できないを受け入れる来なかったのです認めたくなかったです現実を直視したくあり
ませんでした
大学生になって今まで利益なかった混乱が増えてきました
今まではプチ指の特性が大きくこんなに遭われていました
でも俺もと別れて一人暮らしを始めたことで自分の行動をコントロールできなかったん
です
衝動的に行動し手の自分のコントロールできなかった
芽を出します
大学2年生になった春のところでした
私は5月の西にある講演会を企画していたんです
でも5月になっても私はその集客や宣伝を始められていませんでした
やらないといけないことはが真ん中だわかってはいるんです
5月になってい私は彼はらしく話していました
ねえ米議会の surface r 準備始められてないんだよねそんなんか
ああ
あそういえばさこんなことしたら宜しいんじゃないっしょにみんなまで踊る裏塩屋得る
ようよ
なんかその勢いのままに私はその状況で暮らしも部の角を初めてしましたねー
その瞬間は講演会のことはママから聞いてみました
2日後にようやく自分がした構造息づくんです
あっ果たした自分の衝動をコントロールできていなかった
高校生の時はいくら遅刻しても行くらしく回復してしまっても授業中でても
自分に迷惑をかけるだけ
でも今回は違いますみんなを巻き込んでしまって自分の苦手なことで周りに迷惑をかけ
ているんじゃない
社会人としての基本である時間の管理行動のか見ものの完了できない私は
ないから置いていかれた人なんじゃないか
私は自分に迷惑をかける子
自分に人に迷惑をかける自分は無価値だと思い込んでいました
もう
伊佐のこと生きては痛いけど私
属性から離れたいた場所おっぱい
ずっとそんな風に思っていたんです
でもそんな私を支えてくれる出来事がありました
アロエがきっかけです
アメリカもストローラー mc にある自閉症の方だけが来る共通に3カ月間
ボランティアとして
参加することになったんです
スタートして働いていられた一週間だけ
18歳の自閉症の男の子
マイケルと1対1で過ごす時間をもらいました
私はこの1週間ムカデある3つの大事な気づきを
マイケルご覧のです
my ルートは切ってますが楽しく過ごしましたん
でも前にいるわ
言葉を話すことができませんでした
今皆さんは言葉が話せないと聞いて a
どんなイメージがありました
私はマイケルいけばが離せないんだったら
コミュニケーション取れないじゃないか
彼に会うまではそう思っていたんです
でも前には違いました
訪ねの軌跡
まいければ
言葉を話せないけどサイクライダーで自分の気持ちを表現することができたんです
いい
合わせて手話でも私の最後でに対して応答することができました
言葉は知らないけれどからこんな声聞こえてくるんです
僕は幸せなよ次の日びてぃが楽しみだよ
衝撃的でした
だって私は言葉が話せないからコミュニケーション取れないと思っていたんです
ん
でもマイケルにはしっかり感じていることがありました
私は様々コミュニケーションをとるときにこうして言葉を知っています
言葉を得るといっしょ元を取っていますしても前てれば
ただ言葉を発するという手段ではなくタイプライターとしはそしてないければ
キッズと言い方のプロ上でも表現をしてくれました
標準
表現が違うキャラため
ごはんな時
マイ系はフォークを上手に使うことができませんでした
でも食べられないわけじゃなかったんです
私たちは多くを貼付に使うことができます
だからまだま私たちは興奮ユーザーになって
じゃないと言わ噛んで食べることができ
aos 文を選ぶという
だからあいければグラバーんです
マイ系は
私に入っ
leslie 5プ
何かができないということはをとっていることかは全く違うんだよということを教えて
くれました
二つ目が続き
じゃあ
表現の方法が違うだけじゃ
爪だけが生涯の言えないしないのか
そんな仮説置かれたんです
事実としてマイケルはその3ハープの中で一切の生姜に打ちわからなかったんです
だってご飯も食べられるし自分の気持ちの氷冷できる
じゃあなんでマイケルが社会に出た時に
それが将来になってしまうマイケルが障害者と服られてしまう
そんな風に考えてないけど過ごしているとあることに気づきました
私は
コミュニケーション国光覚えてきたご飯を食べる時はこうするべきだ
こうでなくちゃいけないこうであるべきだという
思いをしていたんですね
もしかしたらマイケルにとっては
話せないことをお
フォークを使えないことが
障害難病はなくって
できないということが障害なんでも高くって
私がしていたそのの思富こそが
参りにとって本当の困難になっているんじゃないかな
そうもう少しいうと
社会の中でええ
大学生の人がとって後ろをとっていないから
あなたが普通じゃない
私とは違うから
あなたは生涯さ
いいよああ
そんな女がそんな考えからそんな誰かの思い込み
枚気に入って一気に水世の中を作っていてその中
環境こそが枚手によっている本当の障害になっているじゃないのかなっ
そう考えさせられました
三つ目の続きです
私は背景と過ごしている中で一切の判断しませんでした
っていうのはキャンプの中ではマイケルが組ができるかといえばできないかというとは
全く言えばじゃなかったんです
じゃ髪がないさっ
に見えるがその時どうしたら楽しめるのか
それができるようにするためにはどうしたらいいのか私には何ができるのかをどんどん
発送して実践していることこそがないしちゃったんです
違いにそのマイケルが声が自分追い出したい季節
1週間はと思いました
私もしかしたらこの枚けれど発想の仕方を今まで自分自身を愛して受けていなかった
じゃないか
逆の言い方をすると私は自分史に対してい
今は霊的なそうするべきがー
そんなっ
締め付けをしていたんじゃないのかな
もしかしたら私はこういう形をしている
自分で書いたんですけどちょっとオーストラリア対石井退院しました
あまりは作れないですけど
私は各に行く前までこの企画にい
社会の幕に自分を当てはめ用としていたんです
でも当てはめようとするとやっぱりハゲているところが出てくる
私はその自分のハミれているところを攻め気をつけてみました
でも大事だったのは本当は自分を社会の負けに
明男なようとすることではなく
まず
自分自身も優しいはクレー
自分の寝言を囲ってあげることが考えです
私はたまたまキャンプという発表を言ってい
マイケルであって自分自身の考え方を変えることができました
でも社会を見てみた月に
きっと私みたいな境遇未定
苦しいでいい人がいっぱいだと思うんです今も効か自分のことを絞め続けているかも
しれないです
皆様
思われましたか
生きているのに自分から離れられない
だから箸を持ったを自分のことを受け止めて自分の生かし方をしていきたいとも
[音楽]
駒西
皆さん何を表しているか知っていますか
ませんわー
学習味方行動でどちらかに
混乱のある児童生徒の数だと言われてい
例えば42ひどく落札するとおよそさんにマヌケです
say
少なくないと思います
そして a
3100%が行動名で1周し今何をしています
でも
その子どもたちの
関数が授業中もしくは学校で必要無し受けられていきたいです
私は
子どもたちがただ学校が提供するのナビの方法にマッチしていないだけだと思うんです
マッチしていないのさはにしてもらうことでありません
待ちしていないことが劣っているとか欠陥だとかそういうわけじゃないと思うんです
もしこの子たちがマイケルとしていたよなぁ
剤が数の人が取るしますない工法ていたとしてその手段を受け入れてくれる受け皿
社会の中にあったらその人たちの生きにくさというのは解消していけるんだと思ってい
ます
ちょっと手を出します
皆さんメカにかけられていますか
ね金とかコンパクトメイクしてるよって言い方はどれ位いらっしゃいます
結構いらっしゃいます私前のコンパクトメールしているんですけど
弱からそのメガネのコンパクトベンツマークして生活してください
そう言われたらどうですか
多分多少なりとも生活の中で生きにくさを感じると思います
私が作りたい受け皿というのはこの女がいるようなのが
メイン言えない障害のあって歩いさにとっていたてなくほら応じたにとっても目が女
みたいな自分の
ちょっと人とは違う形をしている部分を受け入れている
メガネみたいな受けたら買ったらきっともっと楽になるんじゃないかな
そんな風に考えているんです
私の坂に共有レザーをつけていません
子ども達が自分が学びやすい校目地獄をデータを育んでいけるような場所を作っていき
たいと思っているんです
でも世界は変えていくためにはまずは個人の考え方を変えていくことが必要です
だから今日私はここに立っています
私は最初皆さん
あなたの中のできないとかへの思い込みをもっと
まずはできたものに変えたいと言いましたん
大事なのは
まずできない中にぶち当たったときそれを責めることでも上げることでもありません
話のことでもありませんまずはそれを知ることです
自分の形を知ることが大事なんです
私は社会のて自分を当てはめようとしていました
完璧になりたくて自分の形を変えようとしていたんです
はみ出た部分も欠陥だったかそれはマイケルが教えてくれました
このはみ出た部分は様々学教が学校が提供した僕
社会が提供しているわけに安否が当たっただけで決して悪いことではありませんをとっ
ているところではありません
一人でバランスを膨らましていいと私は思ってい
もしかしから学校では見方が強化頑張れよ
バランスたレイヤー全部自分でできるようになりがこんな風に折れるかもしれません
昨日今皆さん社会でどうですか
必ずしも社会に出たら
そうじゃないと思っています
自分のへこんでいるところは誰かのお得なところを受け止めてあげられるような
伸ばしてあげられるような動作になるかもしれない
自分の
寂れているのは私が高校の時大学の時
はみ出しているできないところだと言って攻め続けていたところをもしかしたらいい
この部分がへこんでいる人を支えてあげられる要素になるかもしれないです
自分の苦手なところ徳家心は両方とも誰かがつながるパイプニナゲールんです
そして a
自分のよ皆知っていることこそ強くなるん
そした皆さんもう強みしかなってないですか
苦手なところも得意なところも誰がでください
愛され岩見をすることもそ強み
そんなどもが増えてきたらちょっとワクワクしてきませんか
ぜひこの考え方をまずは自分自身に配して約200新
そして必ずきっとあなたの場合が現れます
昔の私みたい
できないことに満ちあたって自分を責めている人が現れ初です
その時に私が今話した内容をぜひ思い出してください
そしてその人に言ってあげてください
海上分あなたは仲間のまでみんな4 a
自分の形を変えようとしちゃっていいんじゃよ
まずはあなたの形を一緒に知っていこう
ありがとうございました
th